you're watching slide on the show this
week all you need is go out the
technology changing the way we shop at
Christmas searching first answer how
Google is charting father Christmas's
delivery run and grab your sports
friends our take on some of the best
titles for Christmas in our games review
hello and welcome to slight from here
london's famous oxford street this week
we've been so busy christmas shopping we
decided to make a whole show about it
you've only got a few days left to get
those prezzies and if you've been
physically out and about why i live
instead of shopping online you might
have noticed a few bits of tech changing
your shopper experience Stuart has been
cruising the aisles Christmas shopping
it's cold outside boiling inside you
laden with bags and you just want to pay
for that last present what if you could
complete the transaction using your
gloves it's just one of the new
innovations changing the way we shop I
think customers like things that they
actually find valuable so if it's
something that is useful and practical I
think customers like it if they start
thinking is an intrusion or their data
is just be
round of them and they might become
worried about that thanks to technology
you can try out a new hairstyle using
augmented reality or have products
suggested to you based on your
personality shoppers seem very engaged
with this type of technology in store as
long as it's colorful and interesting
they'll approach it they'll interact
with it often with their friends if you
design it right these things can be
quite engaging for consumers they can
learn a bit about the product they can
discuss what they want to buy there's
also the technology there's a little bit
more personalized so take buying a sofa
for example use a 3d model to choose
which shape you'd like and then the
color and the fabric I'll go for some
blue lets me see it before I buy it I
could change my mind I go three seater
now actually I prefer the to this kind
of tech is impressive but if you've
chosen to come into a real shop instead
of going online do you want things to be
this complicated I think the children
they don't all the gadgets but Phyllis
old people I like to just browse I think
it's a bit weird it's just a little bit
it's a bit creepy I think I'd rather
just have something on a shelf try it on
in a mirror if it's like clothes for
example and just you know by the
old-fashioned way when you go to the
shops you want to go
should be like shop during recessions
much is made of how best to use empty
shops and technology can have a role
there too we specialize in taking empty
retail units and converting them into
something which is really engaging for
the consumer and we call those digital
pop-up windows and they're cool because
we put a lot of technology inside them
so we've done twitter-based window
displays we've done those with a bit
high resolution video displays and a
whole bunch of other similar technology
based activity it's easy to think of
shopping as a choice between two
approaches online or in store while
that's largely true the lines are
blurring though of course it's the end
result that matters stuart duggan sky
knees well joining me now is tammy
Hargreaves from barclaycard and you
might recognize what she's got with her
some contactless gloves which you saw in
stews piece there now you're going to
show me how to use these up I am
absolutely this is our latest innovation
in payment white walls it's called
pegler we are in prototype mode right
now so we
or out in the market the globe that
you're putting armed contains the
contactless chip in the right angular so
we're going to make a little transaction
in a moment but they like where's the
chip the chip is concealed within the
front of the right hand side ok and what
are you one of these things these are
touch sensitive so basically when you
have about again you don't want to take
your gloves off to answer your phone or
use your smartphone yeah or when you're
texting and it's cold outside and I can
keep goes on that's great ok so let's
get paying for something then and it's
by those copies that we talked about ok
let's sir well I wish copies cost one
penny so you look for contacts in love
pride and then if you
I never color I think Joe's really safe
fastest important to see a little safer
or could i accidentally go around paying
for everyone's copy you really couldn't
really a safe and secure so what we've
just done there is presented the trip to
the reader near field communication had
a lead range and so therefore you what
they will pick up your read and often it
will call clash if it doesn't connect
with the right card in the right Cox'n
looking things they know but we also
offer one hundred percent for guarantee
for any mistakes going back to the
weather these weatherproof what they
bring my food so you're out and about
during the festive period and these get
down there water through so you're good
to go with a lot of wearables though
some people tend to say or they don't
look very trendy or they look a bit
clunky and not so cool I'm not saying
these aren't trendy but are they going
to come in other colors or patterns so
as you mentioned these were prototype
right now when we're out there just
might be back and understanding whether
or not it was a real viable options we
going forward one in five of our
customers that we surveyed said they
really wanted to see gloves as anywhere
ever product to go forward after you've
all taken
is going to be a real huge in a fashion
and wearable tech savvy na Greaves
thanks for joining us that's gonna have
those coffees you're watching flight
still to come there's a wolf among us
keep watching for our games review that
guy's not the wall anyway now it's time
for a round up of some of this week's
best tech stories like going away for
the festive period here's a device that
could give you peace of mind about your
luggage in the future it's called the
smart unit and tracks your bags anywhere
in the world it can also alert you if
your luggage has been opened the battery
apparently lasts for a week it's makers
a crowd funding to develop the project
if you're not up to exercising in the
winter weather here's an idea virtual
reality workouts fitness app runtastic
says it's developed software for oculus
rift allowing where is to strap on the
headset and be whisked away to a whole
other world to get squatting and lunging
with a virtual trainer although the
exercise bit is real tracking father
Christmas has stepped up a gear the
elves that Google have boosted the
Children's Santa tracker app to include
daily games coding projects and
surprises in the run-up to his epic trip
around the world now you know that
feeling when you've eaten all the
Christmas food you can handle you
watched all the Christmas movies you can
bear any reason sorry
a bit of your relatives but not you mind
that because I never get bored of you
but sometimes you just need something to
pull you away video game anyone its
course so yeah ecology advanced warfare
it's the usual sort of split personality
of call egeria that you've got going on
which is you've got a single player on
one side and the multiplayer on the
other side most people tend to stick
around for the market fire but you
should probe a single player because it
is a ridiculous rollercoaster ride of
fun with Kevin Spacey if you just want
to sit there and see a Michael Bay esque
level of building's exploding at you
everything blowing up if you're looking
for now is death call of duty you may
not be the one for you but if you're
looking for just fun and things
exploding and you shooting lots of guns
everything and you've got these exile
bilities and then you can do double
jumps up into the air you can cloak and
all stuff like that if you are looking
to play this one online over Christmas
over this one's duty advanced warfare
the wolf among us which is made by the
people that made the walking dead series
of games which is telltale games and it
has all of Noah detective story where
you play a guy called Big B who's the
big bad wolf and he's investigating
everything of Fabletown there's been a
murder in favor of town it's a noir
style murder mystery things going on and
every choice you make carries over into
each game so if you say a certain thing
to a certain character that character is
going to remember and you're going to
call you on it like three or four
episodes down the line it's like to me
it's the ultimate evolution of the
adventure game sort of like monkey
island stuff for that if you really want
to just sit down honking and play a good
seven or eight hours of game over
Christmas oh you don't talk to anyone
you just want to sit and get lost in a
world this is the game to play
sports friends which is only available
on the PlayStation 3 and PlayStation 4
at the moment now it's a collection of 4
multiplayer games but the standout is
johann Sebastian joust absolutely
amazing and this is the game if you want
to gather the whole family and have a
ridiculous amount of fun this is the
game to get you hold the controller
sideways there's nothing on the screen
you just have to make sure your
controller doesn't move so you hold it
but then three other players like four
other members of your family they're
trying to make your controller move so
this now becomes a sort of cat and mouse
game where everyone standing around like
doing this standing to the side looking
at each other they'll be diving over
sofas people trying to slap controllers
out of each other's hands it's
ridiculously fun it's probably the best
party game I've played in a long time so
sports friends big thumbs up for family
for the Christmas well that's it for
this week but don't forget you can start
today with all the latest tech stories
on Sky News for ipad smartphone apps Sky
News calm and our YouTube channel i'm
off to finish my Christmas shopping I'll
see you in the new year happy Christmas